i'm here in new york with uh sheza
shanlen who's the founder of the malala
fund i'm sorry i might have just
butchered your last name um
uh
can you tell us a little bit about what
the malala fund is and what you hope to
accomplish
sure the malala fund is a non-profit
organization that believes in a world
where every girl is in school
and empowered with the skills to improve
her life and be a change maker in her
community
and it comes really from malala
yousafzai's vision
which is that every girl have access to
a quality education
and so just for people who may need a
little reminding who is malala and how
do you know
malala grew up in the swap valley she
was an education campaigner starting the
age of 11.
and really she was saying i want to go
to school which was a political
statement in the swat valley where the
taliban had banned female education
i mentored her very early on and she
became very close to me as
someone that i believe is a younger
sister and also just an immense icon for
peace
and girls empowerment
and she was shot in the head by the
taliban on her way home from school last
year
she survived after an intense period of
recovery and then went on to become an
icon of the girls rights globally and
i've had the privilege of being by her
side and helping her build a movement
that hopefully will get girls into
school and the malala fund started uh
more basically
when she had been shot and she was sick
you were involved in trying to get her
the best possible medical care and
managing
the press circus that sort of grew
around and that sort of was the genesis
of this
well yeah i went in
um because i was just so
broken at her shooting and wanted to be
there
and
the story had exploded internationally
this young girl who'd been fighting for
girls rights
so brutally targeted the world was
riveted
and everyone wanted to know who she was
and what gave her this courage
and there was a lot of press trying to
get in touch with her so i stepped in to
give her the space to allow her to
recover and while i was there by her
side
she woke up and said i want to continue
my campaign
and it was clear that she could now help
the world in a way that she hadn't been
able to before
and so my role really became how do we
think about leveraging her voice in a
way that's effective that brings focus
to the issues that matter and creating a
platform that drives all this energy
around malala into meaningful action
and why is girls education in particular
girls education so important not just in
pakistan but around the world
well we believe that girls are the most
powerful force of change in the world
if you can invest in a girl between the
ages of 10 to 14 before she is married
and becomes pregnant you prevent her
from falling into poverty but also you
give her choice choice over when she
marries when she has children and the
ability to earn an income and we know
that ninety percent of every dollar that
that a woman earns she invests back into
her family as opposed to thirty to forty
percent for men so not just is this a
moral imperative but from a
developmental perspective is the single
most powerful intervention that we can
make
and your your fund has just started
raising some some money you've had
investments from the world bank from
brad and angelina pitt
but that's not been your focus so far
going forward you're hoping to raise
some money and do do do what would that
be
you know we have really taken our time
to allow mala to recover but also to
spend
our time having conversations with smart
people in this space who are trying many
different ways to get girls into school
because for us it's about figuring out
how to have impact and it's a complex
issue it's not a simple solution
and when you say i want to solve girls
education globally that requires
bringing together the smartest people
and getting them to collaborate to
gather insight and shed light on that
insight as an organization we have three
focuses of our strategy the first is
finding bright promising entrepreneurs
in the developing world who are getting
girls into school and building their
assets
the second is advocating for wider
adoption of the solutions that we think
are effective and the third is
continuing to tell the stories of girls
who we believe are the most powerful
force of change and on that third uh
point there's a new book out uh you want
to tell us a little bit about this book
yes
so the book is called i malala again in
response to the taliban's question of
who is malala
and you know we knew everyone wanted to
know malala's story and there were many
different ways to go about it
but the best way would have been for
milan to take a year and really write it
in her own words and so that's what she
did as she was recovering starting in
the hospital continuing on the weekends
during her time at school and really
hoping this will be an advocacy tool
that will inspire other girls who are
struggling for their rights and also
shed light on the plight of girls
globally
so we have just time for one more
question you left a pretty great job to
go do this you're at mckenzie in dubai
and
you're now doing this full time
so what would it take for you to say
i've succeeded
if you fast forward three or four years
i would say i've done it i've sort of
i've succeeded i've moved the rock
in the broader picture it's about
changing the framework
when i start to hear people saying that
girls education is not just about school
but about empowering girls with the
skills and assets that they need to
succeed in the hardest places in the
world
and when we start seeing innovation
accelerate the delivery mechanisms for
that whether it be through tablets or
computers or traditional schools
that's when we'll know we've succeeded